bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine à
foot ball trap club de ph s'est fait
sortir au 5e tour de la coupe de france
par les mureaux dans un derby yvelinois
sulfureux le score de 2 buts à 1 pour
les joueurs du nord du département le
résumé du match en cette émission
cyclisme sur piste les championnats
d'europe débutent ce mercredi au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour nous parler de la
compétition nous avons rencontré arnaud
courtier le directeur général de la
fédération française de cyclisme course
à pied la 7e édition du trail des sept
hameaux étaient programmés comme tout
les aînés dans la vallée de chevreuse au
départ de magny les hameaux plusieurs
options étaient proposés aux coureurs la
marche nordique un trail de 14 km et un
autre de 28 km plus d'informations à
suivre
gros plan à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football et la coupe de france clap de
fin a pour trappe les joueurs d'arnaud
amisy se sont inclinés contre les
mureaux au 5e tour dans un match où les
saint quentinois en fait un jeu égal
avec une division honneur le score de 1
à 1 patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images
un derby vinoy pour ce 5e tour de la
coupe de france ce trappe qui évolue en
ph recevez les mureaux une équipe de dh
trois divisions dessus des trappistes le
match débute mal pour les saint
quentinois la 19e minute de jeu.les
muriautin marque après un cafouillage un
but qui donne des ailes aux verts la
défense trappistes doit s'employer à
plusieurs reprises pour éviter le but du
break avant la mi temps ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on a un peu près le
même groupe la même défense après
attrape on a toujours eu l'esprit
guerrier donc on là ça s'est ressenti
aujourd'hui et sur tous les autres
matchs
au retour des vestiaires trappe revient
avec de meilleures intentions et fait
jeu égal avec les mureaux et rouge
exerce un gros pressing et monopolise le
ballon par 1 0 à la mi temps on a un peu
de mal à rentrer dans le match bon on a
été un peu secoué la mi temps on avait
dit qu'on la verra la paire pas de
pression et on a joué un peu plus libéré
du bon sens a ressenti sur la d
habitants malgré le jeu développé sur la
seconde période les mureaux marque à la
80e minute sur corner 2-0 trappe réduit
le score dans les dernières minutes sur
penalty par hamidou sissoko un but
anecdotique les verts l'emportent 2 1 et
se qualifie pour le 6e tour c'est une
défaite logique donc l'écart de nouveau
très attendu à shangai ses murs abondera
dans la maîtrise
le sang froid ils ont marqué dans les
moments clés donc après nous on essaie
d'exister mondiale comme un écart entre
une place en dh on prend le deuxième but
sur un coup de pied arrêté à dix minutes
de la fin ça joue sur des détails voilà
il ya on a vu la différence de niveau
son deuxième but maintenant c'est à nous
de bosser pour pouvoir le revendre un
jour tu rappes va à présent refermer
cette parenthèse coupe de france pour se
reconcentrer sur le championnat
les joueurs d'arnaud mbc son 12e 2 ph
après trois journées disputées
une mauvaise nouvelle pour trappe mais
une bonne pour les yvelines le
département comptera à 4 représentants
6e tour de la coupe de france les
mureaux que les mureaux qui ont éliminé
les trappistes sont abonnés aux clubs de
ph et joueront contre les claye-souilly
de son côté le fc mantois se déplacera
sur le terrain de vie vire pour un match
entre équipes de cfa voici se rendra à
bobigny pour ce sixième tour enfin
versailles qui a étrillé ce dimanche les
ultramarines 8 à 0 recevra le blanc
mesnil le prochain tour se déroulera le
week-end prochain du ballon rond on
passe au ballon ovale tout va bien pour
le sky rugby dans le championnat de
promotion d'honneur et saint quentinois
se sont facilement imposés contre
marcoussis à ce dimanche le score est
sans appel
quarante cinq à dix au classement le sky
est premier avec trois victoires en
trois matches et 14 points engrangés
depuis le début de la saison rambouillet
de son côté est quatrième du championnat
si tout va bien du côté est du sky rugby
plaisir va encore mieux les joueurs de
genlis ont enregistré leur quatrième
victoire consécutive dans ce championnat
de fédérale 3 en 4 matches disputés leur
victime du jour à boulogne billancourt
les plaisirs oies les ont étrillé à 44 à
7 une victoire qui ne permet pas à
plaisir de prendre la tête du
championnat cette poule 2 de fédérale 3
est toujours dominé à paris sont en jce
du handball à présent rien ne va plus
pour les féminines de mon team retenu
lésigny montagne se sont inclinés 26 à
22 sur le terrain de lisieux à
l'occasion de la 4e journée du
championnat de nationale 2 au classement
montini se retrouve à la 10e place sur
12 équipes le bilan est de trois
défaites et une victoire depuis le début
de la saison en basket l'équipe senior 2
e s et attrapes s'est imposée 89 à 80 ce
samedi dans son gymnase contre l'union
sportive fécampoise c'est la première
victoire de la saison pour les
trappistes qui remonte à hauteur du val
de seine au classement est à trois
points du leader prochain match pour les
saint quentinois le samedi 29 octobre
sur le terrain de marly-le-roi course à
pied à présent le traite des sept
hameaux était organisé pour la septième
fois à manier la mosson dimanche cette
année plus de 1200 coureurs se sont
inscrits pour la compétition au
programme plusieurs options les runner
pouvez choisir entre la marche nordique
le 14 km ou encore le très sportif 28 km
qui fait partie du challenge trail des
yvelines comment gérer une course aussi
longue avec des dénivelés est dans la
vallée de chevreuse notre journaliste
patrick jacques de dixmude est allé
demander la recette aux participants
juste avant le départ
avec beaucoup d'humilité
et en essayant de rester sur des
sur un rythme que l'on connaît et puis
là il ya beaucoup dénivelé au départ
surtout donc on va essayer de passer les
bars tranquillement pour revoir après ce
qu'on veut faire ah non mais moi je gère
plus c'est une mauvaise question là je
gère plus la distance jeunes et dans les
jambes depuis longtemps et je viens que
pour le plaisir la détente et le beau
temps je vais partir lentement et
j'accélérais au fur et à mesure à partir
de la moitié de la course ça change
aussi spécialiste de l'ultra trail et
que le dernier que j'ai fait c'est la
verbier saint bernard de 61 km de long
et 4000 mètres de dénivelé donc là ça
valait un petit peu vite pour moi ça va
être un petit peu court non je vais je
vais m'accrocher tout simplement s'il y
en a bien un qui a réussi à gérer sa
course c'est lui à bertrand gans du club
de la c1 verneuil le cour a aussi
remporté la course de 28 km en 2h01 avec
une moyenne de 13 6 1 km heure le
sportif a devancé de près de 11 minutes
le second alexandre à quétier la planète
cyclisme tournera une nouvelle fois
autour du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
championnats d'europe débutent ce
mercredi à dans la structure les
meilleures nations du continent européen
comme l'angleterre l'allemagne ou encore
l'italie seront présentes pour nous
parler de la compétition nous avons
rencontré arnaud courtier le directeur
général de la fédération française de
cyclisme les championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste sont organisées au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du 19 au 23 octobre pour nous parler de
la compétition je suis avec arnaud
courtiers le directeur général de la
fédération française de cyclisme par le
courtier est ce que ça sera une grande
fête vraiment ces championnats d'europe
bonjour oui ce sera une grande fête
comme à chaque fois que nous organisons
un événement international au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
parce que nous avons des athlètes qui
sont là de nombreux pays pour ces
championnats d'europe un public local
est aussi international qui viendront
une grande fête est une grande fête du
cyclisme avant tout il y aura des
cyclistes de haut niveau on peut le dire
oui des cichlidés au niveau d'autres
niveaux qu'ils soient français qui
viennent du royaume uni d'allemagne
d'espagne de pays plus lointains à
l'europe sportive et est bien plus
élargie que l'europe politique nous
avons pratiquement une trentaine de pays
qui participent à ces championnats
d'europe et la france envoie quand même
une équipe compétitive avec des têtes
d'affiché des têtes d'affiché laurie
berton sylvain chavanel quentin lafargue
des plus jeunes aussi on prépare la
relève pour l'avenir donc ça va être
très très intéressant à observer
particulièrement pour les années à venir
hall est vraiment une opération
reconquête vraiment pour cette équipe de
france qui n'a pas brillé aux jeux
olympiques a seulement fait une médaille
de bronze sur piste on est vraiment
l'opération reconquête un ici et on veut
le faire devant un public saint
quentinois en fait exactement on a
besoin du soutien des saint quentinois
reconquête on oui surtout préparation de
l'avenir une olympiade se termine nous
sommes d'ores et déjà dans la
préparation de la prochaine c'est-à-dire
tokyo en 2020 et donc il ya tout un
travail qui va se faire penser quatre
années qui démarre pendant ces
championnats d'europe est ce qu'il reste
encore des places pour cet événement oui
oui il reste des places on ne sera pas
sur l'affluence extraordinaire des
championnats du monde utilisent
difficile de faire aussi bien mais il
reste encore des places donc j'invite
surtout les saint quentinois à venir à
l'accueil du vélodrome nationale
puisqu'ils bénéficient de tarifs réduits
en tant qu'habitant 2 saint quentin en
yvelines de toutes les communes de saint
quentin ils viennent à l'accueil du
vélodrome avec un justificatif de
domicile pour bénéficier du tarif réduit
et ils pourront avoir des places
dernière chose est-ce qu'en trente
secondes vous pouvez nous donner envie
de venir voir ces championnats d'europe
ici à saint quentin en yvelines je vais
vous raconter une anecdote en 30
secondes lors des championnats du monde
moi j'étais pas un expert de la piste et
dès le premier jour de la première
médaille j'étais debout sur un fauteuil
les bras en l'air en train d'hurler ça
vous prend aux tripes c'est un spectacle
fantastique où qu'on soit assis dans le
vélodrome on voit très bien spectacle
donc même en prenant une place catégorie
3 la moins chère on est très bien
installés c'est un spectacle fantastique
ça n'arrête pas un des sessions démarre
dans l'après-midi finissent dans la
soirée c'est non-stop pour le prix d'un
billet très raisonnable ça vaut vraiment
le coup de venir merci beaucoup à nos
courtiers et je le rappelle les
championnats d'europe c'est du 19 au 23
octobre au vélodrome de saint quentin en
yvelines
sur le plan sportif les coachs et la
direction technique nationale ont
composé une équipe remodelée par rapport
aux derniers jeux olympiques de rio
comme nous l'expliquait précédemment le
directeur général de la fédération
française de cyclisme par le courtier
exit ligne montrent un françois pervis
et grégory baugé et michael d'almeida la
délégation française sera notamment
portée à part la jeune génération
symbolisée par le trappistes benjamin
thomas 21 ans malgré ce manque
d'expérience les objectifs ne seront pas
revus à la baisse on écoute l'entraîneur
piste endurance de l'équipe de france
qui venant
l'année dernière pour la partie
endurance et vu six médailles aux
championnats d'europe en suisse donc
l'idée c'est de faire aussi bien et
peut-être transformer certaines
médailles deux d'argent de bronze en or
donc
donc oui des gros objectif de médailles
et de médailles d'or séquence découverte
à présent le championnat de france de
majorettes est programmée le dimanche
les dimanches 23 et 30 octobre à saint
cyr l'école coûte projecteurs
aujourd'hui sur l'équipe locale les
saint cyrienne qui s'entraînent en vue
de l'événement patrick jacques de
dixmude pour les images quant à fait
après satisfaction tamale elle est comme
ça tu l'attends où tu n'as rouge ouais
photos sur un terrain ce dimanche matin
l'entraînement est plus intense à la
proche du championnat de france de
majorettes de saint cyr l'école et
compétitions organisées les dimanches 23
et 30 octobre au gymnase gérard philipe
le club local et saint cyrienne créée en
1968 espère décrocher cette occasion
deux nouvelles médailles et promouvoir
cette discipline originaire des états
unis encore méconnu du grand public
français
du maniement de bâton et on fait un peu
de gym aussi donc tout ça s'est
rassemblée
ben on fait des danses tout au long de
l'année et on se présente à des concours
solo jo et 1er mai donc le problème à
ces groupes et leurs cd solo solo ont
fait une danse pour les premières
catégorie c 2030 pour les plus grandes
ses trois milieux 30 pour remporter la
compétition les 58 majorettes du club
âgés de 6 ans à 50 ans tout une astuce
faut être une bosseuse après s'amuser
sourire
savoir faire des mouvements faut être
assidu déjà voilà faut centrer ya du
travail personnel
moi je pense qu'il faut surtout s'amuser
faut pas se prendre au sérieux on leur
met des petits thème des accessoires qui
s'allument qui clignote elles sont
comprendre pour les championnats de
france plus de trois cents majorettes
venues de toute la france vont
s'affronter à saint cyr l'école pour
assister à l'événement le tarif y
compris entre 2 euros 50 et 5 euros
[Musique]
on ouvre à présent une page boxe le
boxing club de la verrière vient de
créer une toute nouvelle section dans sa
structure des cours exclusivement
féminin d'aéroboxe un mélange entre
l'aérobic et le sport de combat deux
créneaux animé par une coach diplômé
sont ouverts le lundi de 14 heures à 15
heures et le vendredi de 18 heures à 19
heures au gymnase du bois de l'étang
présentation de secours par l'entraîneur
de la section lucide le faire c'est des
mouvements de boxe en musique voilà sans
opposition donc la personne derrière
qu'il va venir vous frappez donc on
savait vite les bleus qu'on a sur le
visage après donc on a une partie
d'échauffement encore de séance
du renforcement musculaire et étirements
je pense que pour certains du coup il y
avait une appréhension du coup avec le
monde de la boxe et l'aéroboxe en fait
part mais déjà de mettre un pied dans la
salle de boxe et après peut-être qui
sait devenir faire des cours de boxe
anglaise on passe maintenant l'agenda du
week-end
on en parlait précédemment les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste on promet de ce mercredi à ce
dimanche au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une sélection
française rage unis tentera de gagner un
maximum de médailles devant le public 58
ans pour commencer à préparer les
prochains jeux olympiques si vous
habitez la communauté d'agglomération
des tarifs préférentiels sont proposés
on termine ce magazine par de la
capoeira le championnat intervilles de
cette discipline est organisée tout au
long du week-end au palais des sports
d'el en cours des centaines de coma sont
programmées pendant les deux jours de
compétition
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
d'avoir suivi je retrouve lundi prochain
pour un nouveau magazine à 10 il a passé
une excellente semaine sportive
[Musique]